He's the best there is at what he does.
And what he does is design MCU characters.
A set of renderings of Wolverine drawn by
former Disney artist Jason Pastrana in 2017
is making the rounds on the internet in anticipation
of the X-Man's eventual introduction to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Several pieces were posted to Pastrana's Instagram,
and while it's far from the only Marvel concept
art on his page, his reimagined movie Wolverine
may be the most intriguing.
Disney didn't officially acquire the film
and television assets of Fox Studios until
earlier this year, so at the time this artwork
was commissioned, the notion of the X-Men
entering the MCU was not much more than speculation.
Even so, Pastrana went to the trouble of designing
at least nine different takes on Wolverine’s
iconic mask, and you'll notice that all of
them downplay the parts of the mask resembling
the points of his hair, which sometimes seem
to stretch on into infinity in some of the
character's comic book depictions.
It's worth noting the two "stealth" variants
with the mouth and nose covered, a version
with an X on the forehead, and the presence
of a great, big, stinky stogie in every version
where the mouth is visible.
Odds are Disney would have nixed that detail.
Pastrana eventually settled on a version he
liked, something of a combination between
the designs numbered 2 and 5, and designed
the entire costume, front and back.
As iconic as Hugh Jackman's long run as Wolverine
in the Fox-produced movies was, the character
has never even come close to looking like
this in a movie.
"You actually go outside in these things?"
"Well, what would you prefer?
Yellow spandex?"
This version of Wolverine is a lot closer
to what we're familiar with from the comics.
He looks older, downright grizzled, as if
the MCU version of Wolverine would start out
as aged and haggard as the one in Logan rather
than ending there.
The rendering of the face even looks a little
bit like Jackman.
It's enough to make you wonder if, at some
point, Disney execs were kicking around the
notion of porting over the Fox version of
the X-Men to the MCU before deciding to recast
everyone except Deadpool.
"Hey!
It's me!
Don't scratch!
Just cleanin' up the timelines!"
Since Pastrana drew these concepts in 2017,
names that have been bandied about as possible
successors to Jackman skew much younger than
the depictions here look: Rocketman's Taron
Egerton, Dacre Montgomery from Stranger Things,
and even Daniel Radcliffe of Harry Potter
fame have all been rumored to be considered
for Wolverine.
But Pastrana's work is definitely worth consideration.
It seems to be a clever way to fit Logan into
the MCU.
Note the compact, streamlined look of the
helmet and the utilitarian feel of the uniform,
which evokes an aesthetic similar to the duds
worn by agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. or superheroes
with a more militaristic bent.
There's even a sort of belt pouch, or, if
we're being less charitable, a fanny pack,
with a little "X" on it.
It's not hard to imagine another MCU character
making some kind of wisecrack about that.
"What are you wearing?"
"Oh, I always wear this.
This is one of my favorites."
Pastrana apparently does this kind of stuff
all the time, and if you visit his Instagram,
you will absolutely get lost in it.
Other designs of his include an MCU version
of Doctor Doom, a rendering of Riri Williams,
better known as Ironheart, and a version of
Spider-Man if his suit had been designed not
by Tony Stark, but by Shuri.
It'd definitely be cool if at least some elements
of Pastrana's design make it to the big screen,
because, again, it's a version of Wolverine
who seems to fit the MCU aesthetic.
We have the distinct feeling that he'd do
the team justice if he were to put his mind
to designing their MCU look because, what
do you know, he already did it, and it's a
really smart take.
That said, Pastrana doesn't work for Disney
anymore, so it's more than likely another
concept artist will provide their own designs
for Marvel's mutants.
And we'll have to wait several years to find
out if the characters' eventual designs resemble
Pastrana's handiwork or go into an entirely
different direction.
Marvel Studios has not announced the release
dates of any X-Men projects as of yet.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.